l'agenda puisque nous avons un événement
protocolaire et nous devrons quitter la
séance à
14h15 la Suède a pris le relais de la
République tchèque et assume la
présidence du Conseil de l'Union
européenne depuis le 1er janvier
il s'agit de la troisième président
assurée par votre pays c'est aussi la
dernière du trio de président qu'il
forme sur 18 mois avec la République
tchèque et la France nous vous
remercions d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin pour présente cet
après-midi pardon pour présenter devant
la commission des affaires européennes
du Sénat les priorités de la présidence
suédoise cette présidence débute dans un
contexte de très grande incertitudes le
conflit en Ukraine dure depuis bientôt
un an et nul ne peut prédire son issue à
ce stade sur le front de l'économie la
crise énergétique et le rebond
inflationniste ont assombri les
perspectives certains noms sans même une
récession profonde et durable mais
plusieurs économistes viennent de revoir
à la hausse leur prévision devant la
résilience de l'économie européenne qui
étonne par une demande toujours soutenue
un marché du travail encore tendu et une
adaptation rapide en matière de gaz
nous savons que votre président sera
très attentive non seulement à assurer
la sécurité en Europe qui est le besoin
fondamental mais aussi à y conforter la
croissance la compétitivité l'une de vos
priorités en même temps que les
transitions écologiques énergétiques
c'est pourquoi votre pays en tant que
faire de la dimension durable un
avantage concurrentiel il annonce ainsi
vouloir encourager l'économie circulaire
ce qui nous semble un effet prometteur
nous sommes toutefois inquiets ici au
Sénat de l'articulation entre la
transition écologique prévue par le
Green Deal et la croissance notamment en
matière agricole plusieurs évaluations
estiment en effet que le verdissement de
l'agriculture va entraîner un recul
sensible de la production de 5 à 20% ce
qui m'est en péril l'autonomie
alimentaire européenne dont la guerre en
Ukraine montre l'importance la Suède
entend-t-elle faire la soupe de la
souveraineté alimentaire une priorité
pour l'Union européenne
nous relevons aussi l'ambition suédoise
de faire de l'Union européenne un leader
en matière de commerce électronique et
de technologie pour rester compétitive
c'est une ambition que nous partageons
aussi et à cet effet nous soutenons la
nécessité de revoir les règles
européennes de concurrence or votre pays
très attaché à la libre concurrence ne
l'évoque pas croyez-vous possible que
l'Union européenne devienne un leader
industriel sans que l'on modifie le
cadre réglementaire actuel de la
concurrence en Europe
votre pays s'engage ainsi à lutter
contre les prix élevés de l'énergie et
fait de la réforme du marché de
l'électricité une priorité sur ce sujet
auquel la France est bien sûr très
attachée pourriez-vous nous préciser
quelles options la présidence suédoise
envisage-t-elle enfin la présidente
suédoise entend mettre l'accent sur les
valeurs démocratiques de l'État de droit
elle soutient à ce titre une adhésion
rapide de l'Union européenne à la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme c'est un sujet de préoccupation
pour le Sénat car cela pose la question
de la compétence de la Cour de justice
de l'Union sur les violations des droits
fondamentaux lors d'action menées par
l'Union au titre de la politique
étrangère et de sécurité commune cela
soulève des difficultés à la fois
juridiques et opérationnelles avec un
double risque à la clé celui d'un
contournement des traités et celui d'une
fragilisation de la peste
la présidente suédoise est-elle
sensibilisée à ses risques importants
auxquels nous sommes sensibilisés
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur nous avons une
commission commune des trois commissions
des lois des Affaires étrangères et
européennes tout à l'heure justement sur
ce sujet qui nous semble essentiel
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur avoue la parole
et nous laisserons brièvement nos
collègues poser des questions en se
limitant dans leur intervention ils
peuvent déjà s'inscrire s'ils le
souhaitent
sur le bouton Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
voilà très bien dès qu'ils sont rouges
très bien mais merci monsieur le
président
mesdames sénatrices monsieur les
sénateurs merci pour cette opportunité
de présenter les priorités de la
présidence suédoise
comme vous l'avez déjà mentionné c'est
la troisième fois depuis notre adhésion
en 1995 que nous assurons cette
présidence tournante et comme vous le
savez avec la France et la République
tchèque et je voudrais en fait commencer
par saluer c'est de présidence
puisqu'ils sont su mobiliser le à un
moment très difficile pour apporter une
réponse ferme et unie envers la Russie
et en témoignait d'une solidarité
absolument infaillible à la population
ukrainienne
elles sont aussi menées de très bonnes
précédents dans le sens qu'elles ont pu
en même temps vraiment faire avancer de
nombreux dossiers communautaires
importantes
notre président sera impacté comme vous
l'avez déjà mentionné par l'Ukraine mais
aussi par la crise énergétique
énergétique par la crise climatique et
par une situation économique assez
compliquée
la présidence sera gérée par un
gouvernement qui est en place depuis le
mois d'octobre c'est un gouvernement de
centre droite composé par trois parties
politiques les modérés les chrétiens
démocrates et les libéraux dirigés par
le leader du parti de modéré
notre ambition en tant que présidence
cela va de soi sera vraiment d'être à
l'écoute à tout le monde d'être
impartial et de trouver des compromis
afin de faire avancer les dossiers
communautaires
nous nous retrouvons dans une période du
mandat de la commission ou une grande
partie des propositions de la Commission
est déjà présentée au Conseil en
conséquence il y a beaucoup d'actes
législatives autour de 350 sur la table
qui sont soit en train d'être négociés
au conseil soit sont déjà en négociation
intro institutionnelle donc en trilogue
en tant que Président nous allons
présider
environ 2000 réunions à Bruxelles et
organiser à environ 150 réunions en
Suède y compris 12 réunions informelles
ministérielles donc comme pour chaque
président tournante un gros travail
le gouvernement suédois s'est fixé 4
priorités pour sa présidence notre
première priorité
et cela va de soi aussi c'est la
sécurité de l'Union
l'invention russe en Ukraine a
complètement changé la situation
sécuritaire en Europe pour la présidence
il sera important de préserver l'unité
face à l'agression russe
l'Union devra continuer à faire pression
sur la Russie entre autres à travers des
sanctions éveiller à ce que ceux-ci
aussi soit efficace
la présidence va faire de son mieux pour
que l'Union continue au plus tôt
augmente le soutien politique économique
humanitaire militaire à l'Ukraine
il y a tout d'abord les besoins
immédiats pour cet hiver et là je
voudrais saluer la France qui a organisé
une conférence là dessus le 13 décembre
dernier
il faut aussi que l'Union prépare son
soutien pour l'hiver prochain et
commence à préparer la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine
en parallèle les États membres doivent
continuer à accueillir des réfugiés
Ukrainiens la Suède a jusqu'ici reçu
environ 48 000 réfugiés
la Suède a porté un soutien militaire
économique et humanitaire de 900
millions d'euros depuis le début de la
guerre
pour ce qui est de la politique de
sécurité et de défense commune la
présidence va œuvrer pour que l'Union
assume une plus grande responsabilité
pour sa propre sécurité et améliore sa
capacité d'action en étroite coopération
avec ses partenaires
l'agression russe a montré l'importance
de coopérer davantage dans le domaine de
la sécurité et de défense une priorité
sera de mettre en œuvre la boussole
stratégique
notre président travaillera également
pour renforcer le lien transatlantique
et la coopération entre lui l'Union
européenne et l'OTAN dans le domaine tel
que la lutte contre le masque les
menaces hybrides et la cyber sécurité
en outre nous devons renforcer nos
propres défenses nos propres armées la
Suède comme vous le savez est en train
d'entrer dans l'OTAN et va atteindre
l'objectif de dépenses liée à la défense
correspondant à deux pour cent du PIB
dès que possible mais au plus tard en
je voudrais saisir cette occasion aussi
pour remercier la France et notamment le
Sénat pour son soutien à l'adhésion de
la Suède à l'OTAN
la présidence suédoise veut aussi mettre
l'accent sur les aspects internes de la
sécurité de l'Union comme vous le savez
la criminalité ne connaît pas de
frontières il faut renforcer la
coordination européenne concernant la
lutte contre la criminalité surtout
contre le crime organisé
la présidence va aussi œuvrer pour une
meilleure surveillance des frontières
extérieures de l'Union et cela sera un
sujet important pour le Conseil européen
en février
notre deuxième priorité c'est le
renforcer la résilience et la
compétitivité de l'Europe donc vous avez
fait la vision
monsieur le président
la compétitivité la compétitivité est
devenue moins forte ici
qu'ailleurs notamment par rapport aux
Etats-Unis et à la Chine il faut
renforcer notre productivité afin
d'assurer une croissance économique à
long terme en Europe alors comment le
faire d'abord il faut continuer à
approfondir le marché intérieur qui
d'ailleurs fait 30 ans cette année
il faut continuer à conclure le accord
de libre-échange pour augmenter nos
échanges commerciaux mais ceci pour
renforcer notre rôle sur la scène
internationale
il faut parfois simplifier les règles au
niveau européen mais ceci au niveau
national
et il faut investir plus dans la
recherche et le développement au moins
3% de notre pipe c'est normalement la
recommandation ce que ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui en Europe en réalité
les États-Unis et la Chine investissent
beaucoup plus que nous dans ce domaine
à cet effet la surpopécution de la Suède
le Conseil européen de décembre a
demandé à la Commission européenne de
préparer une communication avec des
propositions sur la compétitivité à long
terme en vue du Conseil européen en mars
il ne faut pas être naïf quand nous
abordons ce sujet
en même temps que nous prenons de mesure
pour augmenter la compétitivité à long
terme il faut aussi renforcer notre
résilience dans le domaine qui sont
stratégiques pour nous par exemple les
batteries électriques
conducteur et là nous allons tout faire
pour avancer le chips actes
il faut diversifier nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement
il faut plus de stocks de produits de
première nécessité
il faut miser plus sur l'extraction de
certains minéraux
et dans ce domaine peut-être vous l'avez
déjà lu dans la presse nous avons eu la
bonne nouvelle la semaine dernière le la
découverte dans le nord de la Suède du
plus grandissement de terreur connu
jusqu'ici en Europe qui aura un impact
très positif sur la transition verte
mais ceci sur la résilience européenne
elle a souveraineté européenne
pour résumer il faut une union qui reste
ouverte vis-à-vis du reste du monde mais
sans que nous soyons naïfs il faut plus
de résilience mais sans recourir à une
course au subventions
pour trouver des mesures autour
desquelles les États membres puissent se
mettre d'accord
la troisième priorité et le climat et la
sécurité énergétique la guerre a montré
pour l'Europe tout entière que les
énergies renouvelables ainsi comme
approvisionnement énergétique fiable
sont cruciaux pour notre sécurité
la flambée des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité ainsi que
l'approvisionnement en énergie cet hiver
et l'hiver prochain peut-être surtout
l'hiver prochain figureront en tête et
priorités au début de notre présidence
la proposition de la Commission visant à
réformer le marché européen de
l'électricité attendu pour le début de
cette année sera aussi une priorité
le gouvernement veillera également à ce
que l'Union continue à réduire
rapidement sa dépendance à l'égard du
gaz russe et d'autres sources d'énergie
fossiles
pour y parvenir nous savons besoin d'une
électricité plus sûre et son fossiles y
compris au moins dans le cas de la Suède
et le cas de la France l'énergie
nucléaire tout en respectant bien sûr le
fait que chaque pays décide de son
propre mix énergétique
notre objectif objectif est aussi de
finaliser les parties restantes du
paquet filtre of
nous allons continuer à mener les
trilogues avec le Parlement européen sur
le propositions de révision de la
directive sur les énergies renouvelables
et la directive directive sur
l'efficacité énergétique
une priorité sera également de le
nouveau règlement relatif aux batteries
et leur déchets
le règlement concernant le restauration
de la nature et de l'agriculture sera
aussi à l'ordre du jour
finalement il ne faut pas oublier les
forêts
qui peuvent jouer un rôle important à la
fois comme source d'énergie et qu'on
base de produits durables mais ceci
comme puit de carbone et comme source
pour la biodiversité je pense que vous
connaissez peut-être déjà que
les forêts d'une priorité suédoise 90%
de notre territoire est couvert par des
forêts
enfin la quatrième priorité c'est la
sauvegarde des valeurs fondamentales de
l'Union la coopération européenne est
basée sur le respect des valeurs
fondamentales la question de l'État de
droit mérite une attention particulière
et reste une des priorités de notre
politique européenne en général donc pas
seulement pour notre présidence possible
pour notre politique européenne en
général
en tant que présidence nous allons donc
œuvrer pour que le dialogue sur l'état
de droit continue afin de renforcer le
respect de l'État de droit dans
l'ensemble de lieu
finalement quelques mots sur le sujet de
la migration
il faut que Dieu continue à travailler
sur les différences techniques du pack
du pack migratoire avec le but de
pouvoir finaliser comme prévu le paquet
sous la présidence espagnole ou au plus
tard au début de la présidence belge de
toute manière avant les sélections
élections européennes
à court terme le renforcement de nos
frontières externes doit être une
priorité ainsi que la coopération avec
les pays d'origine y compris sur le
retour de migrants en situation irrigues
irrégulière
le 3 janvier le Premier ministre suédois
c'est rendu à Paris il a choisi la
France pour son premier déplacement dans
le cadre de notre président cela
témoigne de l'amitié entre nos deux pays
et de leaders ayant discuté comment
renforcé encore plus notre partenariat
bilatéral mais ils sont aussi et surtout
pour revenir sur la coordination étroite
entre nos présidences en vue des
concerts européens dans le mois d'avenir
cela montre que la coopération étroite
dans le trio France République tchèque
Suède continue et se porte bien
la semaine dernière comme il est dusage
au début de d'une précédente le
gouvernement suédois a reçu tout le
collège de la Commission à quiona une
ville dans l'extrême nord de la Suède
une fois Stockholm il faut aller encore
1200 km pour arriver à kirona en fait la
commission n'est jamais partie aussi
loin de la capitale de Bruxelles voilà
en même temps les Suédois n'ont jamais
été aussi proche de l'Europe selon le
dernier Europe baromètre les Suédois ont
une opinion plus favorable de l'Union
que la moyenne en Europe
une présidence monsieur le Président est
une grande responsabilité et nous sommes
très fiers de l'assurer pendant les
prochains 6 semaines 6 mois pardon merci
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur c'était
très clair et puis merci pour votre
français parfait il est sûrement bien
meilleur que mon suédois
très de de plaisanterie oui
effectivement c'était c'était très clair
les je pense que il y a l'objectif qui
est fixé sur plusieurs sujets qui ont
été en partie partager pendant la
présidence française aussi bien sûr et
que
nous vous aiderons tant que faire ce peu
apporter au mieux surtout sur l'un des
derniers que vous avez porté qui est
celui du défi migratoire effectivement
je pense que ça doit être vraiment
traité avant les élections européennes
car je pense que ça pourrait être un
vrai cataclysme électoral si ce sujet
était porté pendant pendant les pendant
les élections et de façon
quelquefois
plus abject que ce qu'on pourrait penser
on passe aux questions alors chers
collègues comme vous le savez nous
sommes contraints une minute à peu près
pour poser vos questions une minute 30
pas plus et puis Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
répondra on prend les questions par 3
mais pour l'instant nous il y a Didier
marie aussi donc on prend par trois
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur si ça vous va et
puis vous répondez comme ça donc on
commence par André Richard Jacques
pernix se prépare et Didier Marie
merci président merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur pour votre présentation
j'aurais naturellement beaucoup de
questions à poser mais vu le temps qui
met un parti je vais faire très court
deux domaines qui sont d'ailleurs
liés dans
en cohérence dans le cadre de du fil que
je vais dérouler d'abord sur la
compétitivité le renforcement de la
compétitivité vous attendez
effectivement les propositions de la
Commission en février je vais donc pas
trop vous interroger sur ça mais
naturellement c'est fondamental c'est
fondamental vu la différence de coût de
l'énergie tout particulièrement avec en
Europe en France tout particulièrement
et avec les USA avec en plus inflation
réduction actes cette compétitivité est
indispensable pour pour l'Union
européenne et à mettre en application
très vite donc vraiment vous avez raison
de mettre l'accent sur ça
le deuxième point c'est c'est
sur le pack migration avec lequel vous
avez terminé là on attend rien là la
Commission a
élaborer une proposition de pactes
immigration et je suis bien obligé de
dire que malgré les efforts de la
présidence française malgré les efforts
de la présidence tchèque ça n'avance pas
du moins pas suffisamment c'est
naturellement comme l'a dit le président
rappin
indispensable que l'on trouve une
solution à cet égard on va être en
France saisi prochainement d'un projet
de loi migration moi je dis que c'est un
cataplasme sur une jambe de bois si on
n'arrive pas à régler l'immigration
clandestine à l'heure actuelle donc
comment allez-vous sur l'ambassadeur
faire avancer les choses avec les trois
blocs que vous connaissez enfin je
rentre pas dans les détails alors que la
France a échoué alors que elle a échoué
allez elle a fait quelques efforts la
République tchèque a pas avancé non plus
comment allez-vous faire techniquement
pour
faire faire aboutir cette revendication
la fin j'avais dit deux mots un
troisième juste je suis arrivé en retard
donc je sais pas si vous avez mentionné
l'Iran mais il est indispensable aussi
que l'Union européenne est une position
claire forte concrète en ce qui concerne
la condamnation pas seulement la
condamnation les sanctions à prendre qui
marque vraiment qui marquent vraiment
enfin il y a une proposition de
résolution européenne dont on va saisir
prochainement chers président avec des
propositions concrètes très dures dedans
il faut absolument que l'Union
européenne réagisse très très vite à cet
égard parce que c'est un massacre qui
est en train de s'organiser
oui merci Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur face à Washington qui qui
subventionne massivement l'industrie
américaine Paris et Berlin viennent de
concrétiser récemment leur propositions
de contre-offensive ils ont transmis
cette contribution franco-allemande à la
Commission européenne et ça paraît aller
vers ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
protectionnisme vert européen or votre
premier ministre devant le Parlement
européen s'est engagé clairement en
faveur du libre-échange vous l'avez
encore redit tout à l'heure
condamnant je cite le protectionnisme
qui n'est pas selon lui la bonne voie
que ce soit de ce côté ou de l'autre de
l'Atlantique
donc ma question quelle politique
industrielle et commerciale européenne
souhaite encourager la
présidentielleoise face à l'inflation
réduction acte je prononce aussi mal
suédois que l'anglais
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
deux questions rapides en complément de
celle que mes collègues viennent
d'aborder la première sur les accords
commerciaux donc effectivement la Suède
a manifesté
sa volonté de poursuivre
le développement du libre-échange
plusieurs accords sont en cours de
discussion
notamment avec l'Australie le Chili mais
aussi avec le Mercosur vous savez que
sur ce dernier sujet il y a beaucoup de
tensions et beaucoup de réticences
notamment de la part de la France donc
j'aimerais avoir votre position sur ces
accords commerciaux et en particulier
sur Mercosur deuxième sujet
la politique d'élargissement le 15
décembre dernier le Conseil a pris un
certain nombre de décisions et
d'engagements pour accélérer le
processus
à l'envers l'adhésion des pays des
Balkans occidentaux je voulais aussi
savoir quel était la position de votre
président
merci y aura-t-il d'autres questions
d'accord donc on reprendra une série de
3 donc Monsieur l'Ambassadeur c'est à
vous
merci beaucoup
bon je prends toutes les questions alors
si vous n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient
donc André gatelin Laurent saribet
Colette mélo puis après on arrêtera les
amis oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur encore bonjour et
tous mes meilleurs vœux pour cette
nouvelle année j'interviens notamment en
tant que président du groupe d'amitié
France Europe du Nord et je rappelle que
l'an passé nous avons fait un
déplacement extraordinaire du groupe
d'amitié en Suède à la mi-mai et nous
sommes allés à Kiruna nous avons vu les
enjeux et déjà à l'époque avant que
c'est découverte de
gisement de terrain on avait identifié
très clairement le fait qu'au-delà de
l'extraction de mine de fer il y a des
capacités dans les déchets déjà extraits
de retraités du cuivre et des phosphates
on parle de la capacité de répondre à
plus de 20% des besoins de phosphate de
l'Union européenne donc la Suède joue un
rôle absolument essentiel dans une
autonomie
stratégique oui mais excuse-moi je suis
président du groupe je suis temps en
temps je peux dire des choses
je parle pas tant que ça donc ça c'est
la première chose et je suis heureux que
nous le soulignons moi il y a un point
auquel je me préoccupe dont je me
préoccupe beaucoup et pour laquelle
notre commission a voté un ami motivé en
termes de subsidiarité c'est le projet
du médium freeac c'est à dire de du
règlement en discussion à la Commission
sur la liberté des médias comme votre
pays je crois comme l'Allemagne et
d'autres pays nordiques voir aussi
l'étaline nous sommes extrêmement
sensibles à ce que cette réglementation
certes importante en matière d'état
droit pour la Commission ne soit pas
rabaissement des standards pour nos pays
qui sont particulièrement exigeants en
matière de liberté des médias donc nous
savons que tout ça va se développer dans
le semestre qui vient puisque la
Commission en vie et le Parlement
européen d'aller assez vite
des élections européennes de 2024 donc
ce que nous aimerions savoir c'est
quelle est la position de de la Suède
sur ce sujet parce que le texte nous
paraît allait un petit peu à la serpe
sur un sujet extrêmement délicat
voilà Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous avez
écouté 15 minutes pour nous répondre
tranquillement à toutes ces questions
donc prenez votre temps encore merci à
Laurence de sa façon magnanime de voir
les choses
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci pour toutes ces questions qui sont
vraiment toutes très pertinentes
d'abord en ce qui concerne
la compétitivité
ça a aussi un lien avec la question de
l'Iran
donc on comprend bien qu'il faut prendre
des mesures à court terme
la Suède
est un pays qui n'a pas trop les
subventions
c'est un pays qui un bien le libre
marché etc je pense que vous connaissez
bien la politique de mon pays
mais on a bien compris
qu'il faut prendre des mesures à court
terme pour faire face
à l'IRA on a bien compris comme j'ai
déjà mentionné dans mon discours
qu'il faut prendre des mesures pour
renforcer la résilience européenne
parfois
ça va coûter un peu plus cher
il faut
notre propre industrie de batterie
de cm et conducteurs
etc et on est en train aussi en Suède de
construire de de tels industries
le message de notre part c'est que
quand nous décidons
des mesures à court terme il faut quand
même faire l'analyse quelles seront les
conséquences à long terme de ces mesures
sur l'économie européenne
pour ne pas prendre de mesure qui en
fait
ont l'air d'être efficace à court terme
mais qui ne le sont pas
à long terme et en tant que président de
toute manière notre rôle c'est vraiment
de faire avancer ce dossier notre rôle
c'est de trouver les compromis en
consensus parmi de cet arbre
en ce qui concerne le pacte
migratoire
je suis tout à fait d'accord le
gouvernement est tout à fait d'accord
avec nous il faut trouver
un accord sur ce pacte et on va faire de
notre mieux pour faire avancer les
discussions techniques en cours
sur un certain nombre de de
d'instruments
je pense
qu'une fois on a trouvé des solutions
pour renforcer les frontières
extérieures il sera aussi plus facile de
trouver des solutions pour
les mécanisme de solidarité donc
c'est une bonne chose qu'on va discuter
en profondeur les aspects externes de la
migration
au Conseil européen en février
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne l'Iran
le gouvernement suédois est très très
occupé
ce qui arrive en Iran
est abominable
il faut continuer à faire pression sur
l'Iran et je note que l'Iran sera alors
le jour
de la semaine prochaine quand les
ministres des Affaires étrangères se
revoit à Bruxelles
c'est un sujet qui sera je pense à tous
les ordres du jour des ministres des
Affaires étrangères pendant ces 6 mois
en ce qui concerne les accords de
libre-échange
oui nous sommes en faveur de continuer
de conclure de sa cordes libre-échange
le développement économique la richesse
de l'Union européenne et d'une grande
partie basée sur notre ouverture
donc il faut continuer à
conclure des accords de libre-échange
c'est une façon pour renforcer le rôle
de l'Europe dans le monde
en ce qui concerne l'accord avec
marcusseur je ne connais pas les détails
mais je pense qu'il y a des conditions
qui seront différentes maintenant étant
donné le changement politique
au Brésil
mais en même temps que nous concluons
des accords de libre-échange il faut
aussi diversifier nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement et en fait de
conclure ces accords est une sorte de
diversification de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour ne pas être
trop dépendant d'un ou quelques quelques
acteurs
et donc c'est la Commission qui qui est
responsable de la conclusion de libre
désaccord de libre-échange et nous
ferons de notre mieux de soutenir la
Commission dans cette tâche
en ce qui concerne la question de la
liberté des médias
donc
notre quatrième priorité c'est la
sauvegarde de des valeurs fondamentales
de l'Union et je pense en fait que ça
dit tout
l'État de droit
la sauvegarde des principes
démocratiques le respect pour le droit
humain
c'est une priorité absolue pour le
gouvernement suédois c'est une priorité
dans notre politique européenne
et même si je connais pas les détails
en ce qui concerne ces négociations je
sais qu'on va faire tout pour qu'on ait
une
liberté
c'est un acte n'est-ce pas donc
free medium media freak qui sera aussi
libre que ça soit possible
en ce qui concerne la jeunesse
je ne sais pas si mon collaborateur va
pouvoir m'aider parce que je ne connais
pas les détails
en ce qui concerne cette question
nous soutenons bien entendu les efforts
pour
élargir le programme de rathmos c'est un
programme extrêmement important
on parle beaucoup de liens politiques
économique entre nos États membres mais
ce qui est vraiment
ce qui constitue le lien entre le nom
c'est un membre c'est c'est les liens
humains c'est la compréhension des soins
des autres de leur culture respective et
là le programme des races est
extrêmement important et
en général de de promouvoir les échanges
entre entre les jeunes encore une
question qui est importante c'est
la formation continue
et et là
sur cela la Suède travaille depuis très
longtemps je sais qu'il y a aussi un
dialogue entre la France et la Suède
là dessus aussi pour pouvoir faire face
à la transition verte
à la transformation numérique etc il
faut une formation continue et là les
jeunes aussi jouent un rôle important
merci
écoutez merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de
vous êtes prêté l'exercice rapide ce que
je propose bien sûr c'est peut-être
qu'on se revoit peut-être en milieu de
président suédoise sur une sur un temps
un peu plus un peu plus long en
partagera à la fois les avancées dont
vous nous avez parlé aujourd'hui en tout
cas les perspectives que vous nous
annoncé aujourd'hui vont se transformer
en avancée et ce sera intéressant de
faire un point peut-être en milieu de
présidence voilà
pourquoi pas
bienvenus je glissais à Madame bornas
que nous aurions pu recevoir la
commission quand on l'a reçu ici au
Sénat on aurait pu la recevoir Ouessant
par exemple
ça aurait été intéressant merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur en tout cas merci à vous
monsieur le Président merci à vous
toutes et tous madame laissez matrices
et messieurs les sénateurs merci et
bonne chance merci